There's been this enormous increase in
inequality and that it has multiple,
multiple dimensions.
Uh,
there,
there is,
uh,
more money at the top,
at the beginning,
uh,
I,
Eh,
in Reagan when Reagan in 1980,
he started pushing for the kinds of
changes in economic policy.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
there was an awareness that those
policies would lead to more,
more inequality.
Um,
the idea was that,
uh,
you lower tax rates at the top and you,
free up the economy and deregulate and
the hope was the idea was that it would,
yes,
there'll be more inequality,
but the size of the pie would increase.
So much so that everybody,
even those in the middle of the bottom
would be better off.
They would get a bigger piece even if
they got a smaller share.
Well,
we've had a third of a century now of
this experiment
and we can see the outcome.
They were right,
that it would include increased
inequality
and the sheer going to the top 1% has
gone to numbers between 20 and 25%.
Uh,
that's it.
Two fold increase in the share,
going to the top,
one 10th of 1% has increased three to
four fold.
But unfortunately,
this idea of trickle down economics that
everybody would benefit is absolutely
wrong.
And what does actually happen is median
income make I'm in the middle,
has stagnated income at the bottom.
You saved him worse.
So in the middle income today,
the median income of a in the United
States adjusted for inflation is lower
than it was a quarter of a century ago.
And at the bottom,
the minimum wage has not increased for
45 years.
So I think then an economic system that
doesn't increase standards of living for
a majority of its citizens over a period
of a quarter century end of the bottom
has people worse off than they were
almost 50 years ago is a failed economic
system.
Ah.